لقد مروا بوادي ظل
الموت،
معظمهم ولكن ليس كلهم ​​تمكنوا من الخروج من
الوادي أحياء
ولكن لم يسلموا من أي ضرر
على هذا الجزء من الطريق المطل على
معارك باهاموت وسوليداد، إنه
آمن بما يكفي لتسليم الجرحى
إلى المسعفين
المنتشرين على طول الطريق.  الطريق، نقالة ملطخة بالدماء، سترة واقية ملطخة بالدماء،
هذه القوات عادت للتو من
الجبهة، إنها سوليداد، أخذوا جرحى،
كانوا يواجهون مقاتلي فاغنر،
يقولون إن هؤلاء المقاتلين كانوا يهاجمون في
موجات، والآن يعودون إلى
قتال بري أكثر أمانًا رأوه  كان مكثفا
هناك قوات نظامية تقول هذا
الجندي وأمامهم فقط يقابلون
المدانين ويهاجمون المخدرات بدون
دروع بدون خوذات بالنسبة لهم
لا قيمة للحياة
في "حقول القتل" القصف
مستمر دون هوادة
للمسعفين ليس هناك راحة
في بعض الأحيان لا تمنحنا قذائف الهاون أي
مساحة لالتقاط الأنفاس، أخبرني مسعف الأناضول أن
لدينا العديد من الضحايا
عندما يأتي القناصة، ثم هناك
العديد من القتلى والجرحى من
القوات ينقلون رفيقًا سقط من
سيارتهم المدرعة إلى شاحنة صغيرة
يسمعون ظل الموت، شكرًا جزيلاً